[Musique]
je crois au rêve au rêve dans lesquels
on peut vivre
si vous créez vous-mêmes l'espace dans
lequel votre histoire là se déroulait
[Musique]
rien de l'oeil ne pourra y entrer
j'ai trop amis qui ont rencontré leurs
maris en ligne
[Musique]
je suis des bras john non c'est pas un
thème magnifique avec sa santé je fais
ce que je peux pour rencontrer un homme
bien
il est tellement gentil avec moi il est
toujours prévenant maman je le sens pas
ce type
y'a rien qui tienne véronique elle pense
que john est un sale père mais je crois
sincèrement que ce type là ne
s'intéresse pas à ton argent tu gâches
coffre mais est ce qu'il t'a dit will
allen essaie d'en savoir plus mais
engager une détective privée des menaces
de harcèlement des manoeuvres
d'intimidation et c'est possible que ce
soit pas lui il te ment et on a peur
qu'il te fasse du mal quand je veux
quelque chose je fais tout ce qu'il faut
pour l'atteindre il a même fait de la
prise en prison pourquoi tellement sur
une femme l'âge de droit ne me concerne
pas les gens disent que c'est bien toi
la seule à savoir si vous êtes prête à
faire face aux conséquences et quelles
conséquences vous paraît
je crois que j'ai jamais su qu'il était
pas
tout ce que je peux te garantir c'est de
tenir